[تصفيق]
السلام عليكم جميعا انا حازم عزام الحداد
عمري 20 سنه طالب بهذه الجامعه العريقه
تخصص سنه
اللي رح تمتد على ثلاث محاور نبلش بالمحور
الاول المحطه الاولى بعنوان وشاء الله بان
احيا
قصه حياتي ابتدات في 23 تموز 2002
يوم كاي يوم طبيعي كان في عيله بتنتظر
مولود جديد يدخل على العيله ابو ام بستن
وابن جديد لهم
على الرغم انه بهذا اليوم او بهذا الفتره
كانت مدينه خليل الرحمن محاصره من قبل
الجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وكان المفروض
منع تجول امني الا انه العيله والحمد لله
تمكنت للوصول للمستشفى
القصه بدات
القصه بدات في لحظه الانجاب لحظه انجاب
طفل في نسبه استصفرار تصير القلق النسبه
السليمه للطفل السليم للمولود حديث هي فقط
من خمسه الى ثمانيه ولكن انا كانت قد
تجاوزت 17
وتلقائيا وفي خطوره ملاحظه تم اجراء
اجراءات فوريه بوضعي في حاضنه لمده ثلاثه
ايام طبعا لكم ان تتخيلوا لكم ان تتخيلوا
شعور الام اللي بتكون حامل تسع شهور بعد
صبر وانتظار وترقب ليجي الطبيب المختص
يحكيلها انه ابنها ابنها في خطوره حقيقيه
على حياته يا اما بموت يا اما بعيش بتخلف
عقلي لانه نسبه كانت مرعبه
صار في عمليه تشخيص وترقيب وانتظار وعمليه
بس محاوله تفهموا ايش كان يصير وبعد ثلاثه
ايام وبعد ازاله خطر الاستفرار طلع في
ظاهره غريبه مثيره للقلق اكثر نسبه تكسر
دم نسبه انخفاض نسبه الدم قصه عشتها من
لما كان عمري اسبوع شهر سبعه 2002 لحد ما
صار عمري سبع سنوات حكي كتير وتشخيص كتير
ودكاتره كتير بس يحاولوا يفهموا ايش كان
تم اخذ خزعه من النخاع الشوكي وكان
التشخيص الاول هو عباره عن لوكيميا الدم
سرطان الدم وكان اهلي ابي وامي على
استعداد بانهم يتبرعوا لي بخزعة من رخام
الشوكي بسحب الدم كامل وعاده ترميمه من
اول وجديد بس كانت نسبه نجاح هاي العمليه
لا تتجاوز النصف واذا فشلت راح اعيش بشلل
دائم
على هذا الاثر ونظرا لتشخيص الاولي
لوكيميا الدم
كان في جلسات كل 14 يوم الاحيان كل سبعه
ايام نروح على المستشفى وحده تبرع دم وحده
تبرع دم وحده تبرد ضم هذا الكلام سبع
سنوات من الشقاء والعناء بس بيوم من
الايام كان ابي رايح على بيت عزب يقوم
بالواجب تعرف اهل الخليل
فبساله صاحبه اه يا اخي عزام كيف صار ابنك
حازم طمني عنه بحكي له والله زي ما هو
الحمد لله يعني الله بيفرجها صار بناتهم
حديث ودردشه لحد كان من رحمه الله وفرجه
انه احد المستمعين قاعده بنفس المنطقه
فبيجي بيحكي لابي عن اذنك انا بس سمعت
شغله ماله ابنك خيره قاعد يحكي له والله
ابني واحد اثنين ثلاثه فبحكي له انا بقدم
لك نفسي انا الدكتور عبد الرزاق دكتور
مختص اطفال في في فحص مختص بمدينه القدس
يقوم لحاله مشابهه اتوكل على الله واعملوا
نتيجه بتطلع بعد اسبوع طبعا نظرا محتله ما
في داعي احكي ولانه ما بنقدر ندخل الى
التصريح فتم ارسال عينه من دمي عن طريق
المحسوم ليتم الف حص وبعد سبعه ايام من
الانتظار المحتم كانت النتيجه كانت
النتيجه مطمئنه بعد سبع سنوات من العناء
ابنك ما معه كيمياء ابنك اسطو بسيطه والحل
موجود ان شاء الله طب ايش فيه ايش فيه
كانت القصه بانه في عضو في جسم الانسان
اسمه الطحال الطحال بيكونوا باختصار شديد
يعمل اعاده تدوير لكليات الدم الحمراء
الميته تحت القفص الصدري مباشره هذا
الفخار كان في عنده مشكله بانه بشوف كليات
الضم البيضاء مش بشكل الحقيقي فبفكروا مش
دم بيفكروا مش كلياته وبالتالي بيسحب منه
كميات مرعبه وانه يحل هاي القصه استئصال
هذا هذا العضو وهذا اليسار خلطات العمليه
جراحيه 2009 سبع سنوات وتم حل المشكله
تحسنت الامور وكان انتهاء هذا الكابوس
بانتهاء هذا اليوم
المخطط الثانيه مثلهم وكغيرهم بعد ما اصدر
رزقني فرصه للحياه والنجامه اول وجديد
تاني كانت فتره الاعدادي حتى الثانوي فتره
طبيعيه كمثلهم طلاب مدرسه ما بيعرفوا اشي
كثير بالحياه بس انا كنت بعرف شغله واحده
بس كانت شغله واحده ميه بالميه انه الاهل
يلي بفنوا من عمرهم وبسبيلهم باموالهم
بصحتهم في سبيل منهم ما بستاهلوا يطلع ما
بيستاهلوا يلتقوا من ابنهم الا كل فخر فقط
كنت بدرس كتير كنت دائما اجيب الاول كنت
بهاي الفتره تعلمت الشعر كنت كغيرهم اعشق
الشعر ومطالعه الشعر وكتابه الشعر تعلمت
الرسم ورسمت لوحات كثيره وكنت حريصنا الكل
يشوفها بس بمجرد انه ابي وامي يكون فخورين
فيه مش اكثر هذا اللي بدي احكي عنه بهاي
المحطه والمحطه الثالثه بعنوان
من صراع الى حياتي
كانت هذه الفتره لي الثانويه والحياه
الجامعيه بهاي الفتره كانت فتره الثانويه
او التوجيه من اصعب السنوات عليه بحياتي
من ناحيه كانت فتره كورونا مرض فقدان احبه
بشكل دائم ومن ناحيه انت مش عارف ضلك تدرس
ليل نهار بس بدك تجيب معدل وخايف ايش ممكن
يطلع شو بدك تدرس وللاسف للاسف هذه الفتره
الصعبه ما انتهت بانتهاء التوجيهي على
الرغم اني جبت 91 وسته بالثانويه وعلى
جنبه اني سجلت بجامعه فلسطين جامعه
الحبيبه تخصص تكنولوجيا المعلومات ولكن ما
انتهى القصه هون قصه هذا الصراع النفسي
كان كتير دخلت بحاله الضرب اسعد حالي طب
انت شو بدك تطلع هل انت مقتنع دخلته ايش
بدك تسوي بعد ما تتخرج كان عمري 18 سنه
وتفكيري كان لبعد التخرج وانا ما بلشت
محاضرات لسه
علشان اطلب من هاي الحاله كان كنت انه
لازم اخذ قرار واحد يا اما بصلي لنفسي
لهاي الدوامه من التفكير اللام متناهيه
خذني وتجيبني بالايام ما بعرف وين بتوديني
يا اما باخد قرار حازم باني اوقف تفكيره
وابلش سعره وابني مستقبلي وعلى اثره بلش
اشوف الحياه عباره عن فرص الجامعه
بالحقيقه كانت قصه الاولى كنت بشوف انه
الجامعه اذا بجيب علامات عاليه او تميز
فيها من ناحيه بوفر على ابي منح وخصم لانه
جامعتنا تكرر من المتفوقين باعطائهم خصم
على على
اقساطهم الجامعيه ومن ناحيه ثانيه تميز في
الجامعه ممكن يفتح لي فرص ثانيه احنا
بنحكي عن فرص انا الان اصبحت انسان او امن
بالفرص وبفضل الله وكرمه بدات بحياه
الجمعيه لاحصد معدلات وصلت بعضها الى 97.2
بمعدل اكثر من 94 وتمكن من تمكنت من
الحصول على اعفاء كامل من الرسوم وتمكنت
من التميز بالجمع بفضل الله ولكن حاله
التفكير رجعتي بسنه تانيه حل العلامات
بتكفي يا حازم هل رح تتوظف بعض اي حازم
هلقيت بدك تكون موظف زي باقي الناس
ما بعرف ما خليت ما خليت هذا التفكير كمان
مره يدخلني بهذيك الحاله صار كل تفكير او
خوف من المستقبل عباره عن خطوات لقدام
عشان الاشي اللي خايف منه ما يصير بهديك
اللحظه كان نفسي اكون معتمد على نفسي
مستقل مستقل ماديا وانا طالب وعلى هذا
الاساس بلشت ادور اسهر ابحث عن شركات اقدم
على شركات شركات تدريبة تدريبات اي اشي
وتم قبولي الحمد لله في شركه هون بالقليل
وشركه في الشمال في مدينه نابلس واكملت
بتمريني مع هذه شركه الشمال حتى حصلت بعد
خمس شهور على وظيفه بعمل جزيء ايفر تايم
ون عمري 20 سنه
انا كتير كنت مبسوط والحمد لله الامور
كلها تمام بس انا فرص بدي فرص ايش ما كان
في فرص بقدم عليها فبتلاقيني دخلت في عالم
الفريلانس يا ريت تعلمت جرافيكس وهو بعيد
عن البرمجه بتلاقيني دخلت التداول
بتلاقيني دخلت كل ما اشوف فرصه فيسبوك
بوست
اي شيء قدم قدم ما بتعرف ايش ممكن يصير
بعدها والحمد لله رب العالمين الحمد لله
رب العالمين انا فخوري كتير بالمرحله انا
وصلت لها السقف لسه ما بلغته والاحلام لسه
ما خلصت وباذن الله باذن الله البني ادم
اي واحد يحط اشي براسه خليه يحطه براسه
مؤمن انه هو راح يمشي له راح يسعى له اي
فرصه بتجيك تستغلها ايش ما كانت تكون
الصيف الماضي مثلا اخذت كورس جرافيك
ديزاين لمجرد ان انا حابب اطلع من
الجرافيك ديزاين على الروم الرسام سابقا
في ايام الثانويه
وتمكنت اني اتميز بهذا الاشي حتى صرت في
لان صار بالجرافيك ديزاينر انه فرصه جديده
انا استفيد منها لقدام واعطيت دورات الصيف
الماضي في مؤسسات دورات تعليميه بالتصميم
الجرافيكي
بالختام انا حابب احكي لكم شغله
البني ادم شو مكان حاطط بالعصور ايش مكان
الاشي اللي بده اياه بده يصير مستقل بده
يصير معه مصاري بده يتفوق بده يعمل اي اشي
بده اياه بنقدر بيقدر اذا هو اتخذ قرار
حقيقي وهذا الشيء مش مجرد اتخاذ قرار انا
اليوم والحمد لله ما بطلع من الدار قبل ما
تكون استراتي جاهزه كل يوم ايش بدي اعمل
بعد المحاضرات شو فيه طبعا اروح عندي شغل
صار ايش بدي ارتب امور للشغل ففي ترتيبات
بتيجي بعض القرار بس اهم شيء داخله بقرار
بالختام قصه حياتي بدات في 23 تموز 2022
ولا بتنتهي بعد ولا تنتهي بعد يعطيكم
العافيه
[تصفيق]